It's kind of scary. I
feel like I'm in an underground world. But if it disappears, it's probably
been around for a long time. I guess that's
fine. I was
walking around thinking that I was some kind of great person.
But, I don't think it's scary at all.
[Music] I guess
Kusa is the one who takes care of me when a problem arises. To be honest, I don't really like her,
but I think she's a necessary person.
[Music]
So now...  It was 9pm, so I
slept here with a futon, and I woke up
around 3am.I went to sleep and
started my day by
walking,
breathing in some fresh air, and I was determined to do my best again today.
[Applause] I feel
refreshed.
Haveaniceday.
My name
is Yoichi Nakamura. I've
been with the Sumiyoshi-kai for 37 years and was the
organizing committee chairperson, just because I was called the Lion of Ginza. In March of this year, I
became more serious.
[Music]
Before joining the Yakuza, I
worked in the Self-Defense Forces for two years, working hard in the wake of the earthquake.When I learned about Ginza, I thought that it was a place where men could thrive, with all the good women around, so I left the Self-Defense Force after two years.20  Since I was a young man, I've
only known Ginza and Ginza, so I met a
wonderful boss, and I was captivated by his charm, and I've come to
this day with the mindset that I'm going to die for all my friends.I
think it's a wonderful organization.There
must be around 20,000 people.  Is it true that a
yakuza is only a yakuza when they have trouble, and when they
have a yakuza opponent and
fight with them and win, they're a yakuza?I'm
doing the videos I've been doing until now, and luckily I get
a call from the other person, and
then I
lose.I
hate that it's normal to lose.  So I quit.The
yakuza of today are under
strong pressure from the police, and if they loudly say what they want to do or start a
fight, they can all be arrested.In
prison, even if they just show their prison business cards, they can be
arrested.In this way, yakuza are no longer alive.  I can do it. It's
gone. It's
definitely better now.
Zero stress. Do your best at
Ginza Lion. The
end. It
wasn't my limit.
[Music]
OK. It
feels good.
[Music] There
are currently 22 organizations designated under the Volume Down Countermeasures Act.  In reality,
there are Yamaguchi-gumi, Inagawa-kai, Matsuba-kai, Sumiyoshi-kai, and other organizations.My name
is Norio Tamura, and I am 64 years old.I have
been with the Gunma Prefectural Police for 41 years, and have been
handling burden cases for about
37 years.  The
biggest
advantage is that
there is a 15th item on harassment against each business operator, and on each individual,
for example, against people involved in the entertainment industry,
and against financial institutions.  If
the money is
not paid, they harass the construction company,
etc. It's money
laundering. In other words, there
is a special law that suppresses banks. Well, the point is, if the profits illegally obtained by organized crime groups are discovered, they are forced to close
their accounts.  If you look at their movements
before the anti-violence law was enacted
and their movements after the disaster prevention bill was enacted, it's obvious that it was
after the parent organization was enacted.Of course, it
feels like their appeal has weakened a little.  This
is because
even within the Anti-Bobbling Act, if
each resident raises an incident, they
can earn an administrative punishment called the central order of the Anti-Bobbling Act.Just the mere
fact that an administrative punishment is imposed is a huge
penalty for the gang
members.  The residents of the ward eat each other, and if
this happens again and again, we
can take custody of that resident in order to prevent it from happening again.Then, if we
lose one or two people, the organization
becomes weak.  I am the
president of Sohonmachi. It
is the perfect university. I am in a position to point out Japan's
masterminds, fixers, and Japan's problems, and
guide comprehensive national strategies such as connections with foreign countries and diplomatic negotiations.
As I am the head of the school,
many people from all over the world practice karate,
and within this network,
everyone is
said to be a disciple of the right person, and you are said to be my disciple as well.  Because I have
often supported such revolutionaries,
I am not considered a terrorist by the Japanese government.
With the support of the United States, the administration is putting severe pressure on the Yakuza in a way that, under Japanese law,
annihilating the Yakuza will make them all useful.That's
why I decided to
quit the Yakuza and start a new organization as soon as possible under Article 5.  What was created was the
Ninkyodo, the
Ninkyō organization, which was created for the purpose of civil defense.If
someone was in trouble, they would
help them, or if they were
criminals or people who were running away from doing bad things, the
Ninkyō people would
help the police.  The
same behavior as in law
was carried out by people in the role of chivalry.This was the case in the
Edoperiod,
when Bushido was in charge of politics.This is the
relationship between Bushido, samurai, and popular co-translation.This is a complementary
relationship, where they help each other.  In order to
help the weak of the new era
and build a strong organization in Japan, the
Yakuza will be destroyed, so we will gather the righteous people among them,
those who believe in chivalry and the law.In that
sense, as a leader, I will lead the
Yakuza life.
Yakuza gather from all over the country relying on such a person.Today, I'm going to
meet Mr. Toyokawa Tanaka, the 8th head of the Tamagawa family, the Matsuba treasurer.He
is the boss of chivalry.It is
not a crime in itself to join.  Well, some intelligent organized
crime groups say that the
guns that are used for assembly and association as stipulated in the Constitution are, after all, organized
crime groups are also assembly associations, and
they gather because they believe that the freedom of assembly and association is guaranteed under the Constitution.  For
example, they used to
put up a sign outside the Tamura-gumi, but the
point is that Mr. Gold's organized crime office is located there.The
residents who live in the area filed a
lawsuit, so there is no need for an office in this area.The organized
crime group has been
removed.
There is a law that allows the court to order you to leave if you do something like that,
so
the reality is that people don't avoid the so-and-so group signboards these days.Wow,
young people
[Music]
I was
arrested.  Why don't you just
take it to your friend? [Music]
From Makino I'm
sorry, you idiot who bullied me.
After all, we're both men, so we both have our own rules.
If you follow those rules, you can either
answer or not, and
listen to what you want to wear.  No, I don't ask anything. I do
n't go anywhere. I do
n't hear anything during the 22 hours we interact.
Every day I bring water and coffee, put them out early,
light a cigarette, and when I come in the morning, you say good morning again. You say, "I'll take you there," and we
talk.  I'm worried that I'm going to run out of
time doing something like this.I'm
worried about whether or not it's okay to do something like this.As I've been
involved in this kind of work, I find
it difficult to include other organizations when I'm narrowing down my own island.
After all,
it is the boss of the local organization that has become a hindrance, and
its
form has gradually collapsed.Although no
specific group is allowed to
participate, Taro's group has gradually entered the
island.  You
can't go against the people who are in charge of the Tokyo government.If you do the opposite,
of course the usage relations
will not remain silent.However, as I
said, how do you live in the midst of the encroaching treasures?  I
think it's a matter of human resources.
Driven by profits.As I
said earlier, you shouldn't drive towards
profits.You should
do things without hesitation.That's because
I said that I don't like
medicine.Medicines are the best way to make money.  It's the
quickest way to get it stolen under the Auction Interference Act, because you pay money to get it stolen.However, when it comes to shabu or other drugs, what you buy for 1 yen can end up costing you thousands of yen, so it's the quickest way.  However,
we don't think about the people who are being undermined by
it.Society is different now.At
least we are the ones who
have nothing to lose in the war, so we are okay with it.  The
economic situation in the world has become even more difficult.If we
do something sloppy, everyone
below us will have an easier time, and we are the
real bottom.There aren't any more of
us.  We have to stay strong,
but we
can't
give up and we can't bend our spirit. If the yakuza were to do something rash, they would be
wiped out from the world. They're about to get massaged. That's why there
are so many people like that.
[Music]  ]
That's right, so the rules are strict. If you don't know what's
okay and what's wrong,
it's very
strict. I used to
play in Ginza for 37 years,
but I
can't go there anymore because I'm addicted to it. Well, it's
lonely.  Now, I am indebted to the people in Shinbashi.
From now on, I
am thinking of becoming serious and going wild in real estate, finance, boxing promoters, and the entertainment industry for Japan. There is
nothing I can do for now.  Starting this week,
office supplies will be brought here and the organization called the company will be run here.The
day after tomorrow there will be a big discount and we will receive 25 million yen, but
this will also come as part of a proper business.We
have to create a cool office.
[Laughter]
[Music]
Now the yakuza are acting as brokers and trying to tinker with the land. The
law has become such that they can't do it anymore.
From the yakuza's point of view, the job is perfect. It does
n't matter. It's over.
Goodbye.
Well, I'm a yakuza too.  I've been doing real estate for a long time,
and
I can do anything from celebrities to the showbiz industry and collecting money.The things that are
prohibited in Yakuza work are things like social
turnover,
stimulant sales,
marijuana, and things like
that.  The police are already supposed to take over and
investigate, so
I won't do that kind of thing.
[Music] You
can't survive unless you go into the economy, but the
people who become yakuza haven't even graduated from university, and they have no
brains.  It's not very good,
it's just violence, and even if it suddenly becomes
called the economy, it's not going very well, but there are
smart people out there.
[Music] I
mentioned the number of people earlier, but according to the
Metropolitan Police Department, it's 1,200 people.However,
this requires
registration.  There are probably around 4,000 people who do
not have a Daimon but work and help in various ways.Also, if there
is trouble between organizations, then  He was the
first man to fly away.He
has a manly face, but he has a
violent heart.If
this tightening gets stronger, I guess we'll have no choice
but to change our ways.Japanese
yakuza ca
n't make their business public.In
the future, they won't get too tight.  You'll have to keep your office secret, your
gathering place
secret, and your
group's name secret, with no signboards, or something
similar to Miken.Pick-up
phone number: I
'm
Nakamura.I'm Nakamura.I've
stopped using drugs.
That's what the Internet
can do.The fact
is, these two guys at the top wanted to
decide on me, so I
caused a ripple.Well, I
came here because of his push, but it's
not the kind of money I'd pay.  That's why we
talked so hard on Nikko TV and said, ``There's no way this
bastard is going to pay me.''
In those places, these guys were like, ``Okay,
can I meet that jet-black guy?'' I said I should just make a
phone call, and I called him.
These guys have been waiting for me, and they just carried me away.
Because I'm a man who doesn't hurt myself. Normally, he would have been a yakuza member for 37 years. I
think the shock was amazing. In
my case, it felt good. I
replaced him.  Well, in two days and two days, I
made this office my own.Of
course it's free.One
floor is
50 tsubo in total.  It's
going to be 500 yen,
right now.The
yakuza
can't make money, so the yakuza has no choice but to collapse.Now they're
saying no more confrontations, so for some
reason the above is a
law against violence.It's a confrontation concept that is wrongly used by the general public.
If you say you injured someone or killed someone, you
can now claim liability for compensation.This
kind of law was created, and this is
actually happening, and you're
losing.  This kind of confrontation
means that the way of life of organized crime groups has already changed. Organized
crime groups are now visible and visible in their lives. Do
n't be afraid of organized crime groups.
Don't pay money to organized
crime groups. Don't take advantage of organized crime groups.
[Music]
As usual, I will pass the information
through the investment partnership, so please take care of it.
[Music] I
would like to cancel the contract. 145.1 billion yen. I think this has a lot to do with your work, this venture company
's investment.  In a venture business, you do
n't know if you'll go bankrupt tomorrow, so it's
difficult for financial institutions to invest in it.There are two main
ways to do it: ferment new stocks, manipulate the stocks, sell them off, and make a ton of money.  One is to
acquire stocks in exchange for investment,
send executives to take over the company, and then just take over the company.Of
course, there are no people with this kind of personality, such as the president,
so even if you investigate, you won't find out.And as I
said earlier, things will get worse.
If the
company manipulates the stock, sells it, and goes bankrupt, it will
create new victims, so
all parties involved are told not to pay.You
can deal with it, so you should
deal with it resolutely.  Do
n't worry, we'll definitely be able to repel
organized crime. It's the same with
all these places. Everyone is like that. If we all evacuate and move out of here, a great building will be built. That's why we're
looking at the property on the ground, which means we're
looking at parking lots.  I'm doing it as a real estate business, but if I raise it, a
bigger building will go up, so I want to raise it.That's why I
want to turn this into a business.It
doesn't look like a yakuza.This is a legitimate
real estate business.If you
have money,
please move out of here.  If you
give them money, you'll
end up with a huge building
if you give them all from the front to the back, and everyone
wants an eviction fee, so they'll
go and give us the money.
There's no way we're fighting that battle.  Troubles were bound to occur,
so it
was the role of the bosses of the region to solve the troubles, such as using them to kill people or even killing them [laughter], and
this gradually
evolved into the Meiji era  After that, I
think it gradually developed into the current form of organized crime.The
economic yakuza, dissatisfied people, turned to
traditional gambling, drugs, and
police
investigations.  It's not an easy field to be in, but
as Japan's economy becomes more advanced and growing, when
top-tier Japanese companies earn large profits, they become
involved in some way and
extract money from them.
In Japan, during the bubble economy, there was a situation in Japan
when there was a surplus of money, and when the public society had a surplus of money,
money naturally flowed into the underground society.
For example,
people who withdraw huge sums of money to organized crime groups, such as those involved in real estate transactions and other financial transactions, are
known as economic yakuza.  There are
people who call from corner to corner and use their brains to carry out their activities.In the wake of the
Lehman shock,
traditionally, for example,
people who worked as financial professionals at securities companies or banks
had the know-how.
When the executives of a gangster who was fired from his company because he was involved in a crime were
scouted, they found out that there was no money attached to them.They
were people who would normally be considered sound fund managers, but they managed to manage the funds of a gangster.  That being said,
some people refer to these
people as underground fund managers.Well, to
put it
simply, the source of the funds is organized crime, and they are
doing so.  It's not strange to
say that investing in stocks is a healthy economic activity.However, the fact that the organized
crime group is the investor and the
profits are
returned to the organized crime group means that the
source of funds for the organized crime group increases, and the police and
authorities take advantage of it.  I saw this as a problem, and for the
past few years I have been
researching whether the police can crack down on this.There
are legal technical aspects that make it difficult to clear up, so I came
up with a law that cracks down on organized crime.
There was a huge controversy over whether it was okay to create a
fund.If you were to act as a fund manager and take custody of organized crime funds, invest
them, make a profit, and then return the money to organized crime, even if
laws were made to prevent you from doing this.  As for how to
operate this, I
think it will be a very difficult and difficult operation.Some of the
organized crime groups are
intelligent people,
so they are the ones who are making money from their own pockets.  If
something like this were to happen, it
would be discovered immediately, but there is no way to spend money, and how to crack down on it
would be extremely difficult.I think this is manipulation.If the police strengthened their crackdown to cut off the conduit to obtaining that source of funds.  For
example, in the case of gambling,
drugs are thoroughly investigated and
exposed by the police, and I don't think there are any people in today's society who gamble.
Thanks to the crackdown,
organized crime groups may have entered the public economy.It's
not clear, but they
seem to be turning into an underground organization, and
what the
police are doing is difficult to grasp.  The eeriness is
coming out now.
[Applause] The
first generation of Tamagawa River was in the Chichibu Motomachi area at the end of the Edo period.At the same time, they
gathered together common people and formed a family.Yakuza are not
good at just violence.  You also need money, and you also need to have
good social skills.You
can't really have a serious, heart-to-heart relationship with someone, so when you're a decorative person and you're in trouble, you
do things for other people, but
sometimes you need help, so they
get scared.  Tanja
We haven't eaten either. We don't need
anyone to help us.
[Music] The
general rules of the Yakuza are that those who are shaped are
bullied, especially the
elderly,
wives, women, children, and children.
But
in my case, I'm
from Gunma
Prefecture.I went to Gunma prefecture right
after the end of the war,
and every year I go there to
use it for the Lord, so I do it,
even though it's not that
expensive.  Regarding the disaster, it
would just be a publicity stunt within the town. They
would have to put up a sign saying that the Tamagawa family was there, and
this was
sponsored through the town.
This is just a way of life. The word
chivalry is common among people.
But if you have a heart that won't give in to the strong and
help the weak, it's not enough to just be kind when you're chivalrous.Of course,
we can't live with just these beautiful things.  You can't do
that, so you have to
pay a greeting fee or something like that for the first time you watch the game.This is the
first time the ball has been played, but it's hard to gamble.This is because the
crackdown on this has
become very strict.In
the past, people used to be caught red-handed.  Otherwise, if
someone who was not arrested was arrested now, even non-verbally,
that information alone
would become the subject of an investigation, so it's
difficult to do something like that, whether it's a Hanafuda truck or the best.
[Applause]
That's why.  We have a set of rules: You ca
n't run away from Siri, you can't
run away from me, you ca
n't buy things for your family,
and you can't do
anything that violates the spirit of chivalry.
As a rough guideline, there are about five rules: We will
educate people in that way, and we will take into account those who violate this rule.In
particular, we will never tolerate those who have dabbled in drugs.We will keep
this in mind if it is something.It has been
11 years since I was 48 years old.  Last time, I
got
38 million yen from my boss who ran the shop for me, but things didn't go well and I lost that money, so I
cut my finger off and it
got stuck in my finger. It's
scary.
What would you do if you got hit? I
gathered about 20 young people together.
So, I
tried 123, but my finger was still
weak. 2nd generation 123
[Music]
Still no good. The third and final time, I
got it. It was an
operation. It took two hours. It was my
first time
seeing a doctor.  I'm so sorry, boss, for the past
year that I've been decorating my altar, and I'm
sorry that my flying distance has decreased, but I'd like to ask you to intercede with me.No
one told me that I was being cold on my own, and I
can't use this either, but you.  It's okay to cry when you go to the Philippines.
[Music] No matter
how you adjust the machine, it
won't turn out to be the same color as the hand-
carved one.Hand-carved wood is less painful.You know, it's the same as in
Japan when we first started digging.  It's a
pigment used in Japanese paintings in Japan, but the seeds
contain mercury, so if you
leave this salt on for about two hours, you'll
get a fever of nearly 40 degrees.You
have to put up with the pain and heat only on that day when you dig.  The
more sugar you had, the more you wanted to put up with it, and the more it was
worth it.In
the past, there was something like that, where people
didn't really want to talk about it.I moved
around to various places and joined various
organizations, and that's
how I learned their training.  Yo,
bro,
without joining the yakuza gang, dig a
hole, put a needle on it, throw the needle away, and then
use this in a sterilizer.This is what they used to use in the
old days, back in the
Edo period.This is what we would
call a prison in those days.  But at
the same time, when I was sent to that place, I
got a tattoo on my arm that you could see if you raised your hand even a little bit through the
hem of your kimono.
People like that who were sent
back to the island came back from the
island, were sent to the island, and were
criminals.In the
end, people avoided them because they had a criminal record.Even if they
looked for a job, they
couldn't get one.In the
end, they found a job and
risked their lives to get a job.  That's all there is to it, and
in order to erase it, a culture has begun where people check their surroundings in this way.The
tattoos started with criminals, and that's
where the origin lies, and in the
end, the yakuza and tattoos are
inseparable.  It's like that.From that
era to
ours,
most of the time, the
boss of the group would
get a tattoo, and the boss would pay for this guy, and he would
release this guy to the young people, and
this battle would take place between the
Tiger and the Dragon King.  Until about 30 years
ago, there
was definitely a rule that you had to get a tattoo of yourself fighting.The rule was that if you
became a yakuza, you had to get a tattoo.Sinner
plus
yakuza+
tattoos are becoming less and less common.
Well,
in the end, there
were more carvings on the staff, and the
beautiful women were
all
[Music] [
Applause]
My name is
Furniture.The three-day
inheritance ceremony is an
important ceremony to become the next new boss.
[Music]  ] It is
called a genealogy that shows the history of territory and 10,000 yakuza,
but in the
case of yakuza, it is called soul and soul spirit
[Music] It is
still not practiced in Japan.  You go there and say, ``This was a
choice at the time.Of course, you
had to cook and cook.Even if you were a
monk, everyone was like
that.Athletes came into the world, and
when you were new, you were all like your seniors.''  The rules are that you do
n't want to lose things and
that you have to work hard.I started working here probably about 7 years ago, and I usually
wake up around 8 a.m.,
make meals, and
then, of course, clean the house and do a lot of other things.  I usually
end the day by doing things for those around me, but for
my boss, I'm going to do it until I die.And
little by little, I'm improving myself as a person and how to
interact with people.  Once you improve your skills and
become recognized by the world, you
become a big brother, a
boss, and a boss.Asakusa Higashi
Yakuza
is, after all, a town for the common people, and it is
far from the samurai society.  I think it
developed in the newspaper,
starting with Tatsugoro, and there
were all kinds of yakuza.It was
written that yakuza were people who were in charge, and they
called them yakuza.They came to ask for
troubles in the town,
costs, etc., and took
care of them.  I heard that it was the yakuza who did it.Right
now,
893 is a yakuza, and
it has become synonymous with someone who is not good for anything.Anyone can
join, and if you are a man, you don't need to take
any tests.  No, I only
slept 23 hours a day.So, if there
was a fight or any other trouble, I would be able to
rush there at any time.I would spend another
year, two, three years doing everything from stern cleaning to everything.  The
desire to be a yakuza in our era was created by
watching Ken Takakura's movies and taking a lot of drugs like that.I
admired the coolness of the yakuza and decided that I wanted to be like that too.
If you look at it, you've
reached a situation where there's no one who wants to become a yakuza.
Seriously, you
live in a room for about two years,
but you don't have anyone who can become a yakuza.  Nowadays, we
live in such a time. It's
cold. It's cold. It's
warm. It's hot today. It's not going to be
tough again from October. We're not organized
crime groups, we're
merchants, so I think it's completely different. Organized
crime groups have their
backs open.  I think it's violence to dress nicely and deceive people or even
act like an oracle.I
don't know what to say, but I get
yelled at.Most of the
people who feel that way have already
been excluded.That's
why everyone has stopped going to the street stalls.
[Music]
[Laughs]
I'll be fighting the WBA world title match on Tuesday
at Korakuen Hall. I've got everything
ready ahead of time for you to come. See
you again on Monday. Thank you very much.
Well, the boxing show is going to be next week.  It
happened on Tuesday, but for a while now, I
guess the
yakuza
had been shut down too much
due to ripples. I asked the prefecture to ask for a favor,
but I
don't know if they're making fun of me or if they're making fun of me,
but everyone stopped calling me.
Everyone is running away because they are giving away boxing tickets.The
prefecture has extra money, so I'm stressed out, and
about the industrial money,
well, I guess I'll give it to the other person.If I get it right, I won't be able to make much
money.
Just because I've become more strict about it, I still end up being
weak here. More
violence this time. Well, this is all I've
known for the past 37 years, so I
'll do it when I want to use more violence. I need to do
more.  No.
[Music] I feel
the same as now. I
hate myself for feeling like my heart was about to break even for a moment. Thank you. My name is Fuyu Yamamoto. I
'm a video producer, especially for V-Cinema. My
specialty is
Yakuza movies.
About 80% are Yakuza-related.  For
example, outlaws and yakuza have been part of Japanese culture for a long time,
so
even if we don't affirm that, it's
normal for the average person to be sold as a whole.  The fact that
the photos are more than just the limit
is also common in general, so the theme was to make
everyone aware of the
strong sense of duty and humanity as a part of Japanese culture.
That's
not what I'm saying, but I think the Japanese culture that
still retains its Bushido style is the yakuza society, so
even if there are risks to that, it's unavoidable.
[Music]
First of all,
When you get angry, it's basically not the truth, or you try to make fun of it, or you
make fun of it, and it's been a long
time since you've been in the past.  This is based on the historical facts of ``
When there was a fight between Group A and Group B, it was preferable that Group A
not say that the beam was good, but that Group A
got into a fight with Group B for that reason.''
Group B had no choice but to do so.  Even though we fought against Group A, we
try to look at each other with fair eyes and not to hurt each other as much as possible.
[Music] I was
asked at a hotel if I would like to come to my room for a
while.  I was
forced to pay money because it was my fault, and I was
told that it was my fault and that if I didn't pay, it would be a crime, but I was kept
in the same place for about 8 hours from Nanjing.  There
was a situation in Nanjing, and the
other thing is, I
understand now that I'm sorry, but I
can't get back what I sold, and it's physically impossible to take it back.
So, what to do about it is to just give me the
money.If I pay the money, I'll
take on the challenge, and
there's a possibility that I'll end up sharing the profits with the drug, so
of course I can't afford to pay no matter what.  I
don't have money to pay for things, so I'm
not an insect in that way, but I
do it through my own stimulation.My name is
Yamamoto, and I'm a producer.My father was a
planning producer, and I mainly work as a
producer on set.  The
period is as short as 4 days, as long as 1 month.The
budget is
cheap, about 10 million yen,
and the most is 340 million yen.Also,
about 50 people use it a year.At my
company, it's a bit of a hassle.  I'm
going to do this, so for now, I'm going to
do this alone, or
rather, Cooler is making this so-called hero.It just so happens that the
subject is a yakuza.The Japanese aesthetic club is
teaching us that the subject matter is just a yakuza.The aesthetic that sticks to it
is the yakuza that we draw.
After all, salarymen
don't live their lives thinking about the virtues of humanity or anything like that.Yakuza are the
only ones who
stick to the so-called traditional rules of Japan,
putting their bodies on the line for their parents and
brothers.  I'm not saying it's because he's a yakuza in particular,
because I'm portraying him as the ideal image of a man.If
this was a crime
drama, Mr. K would
make it look cool, so that's what we're talking about.  After
all, you only live once, right? That's
why professional wrestlers are going to
do it. Politicians are going to do it too.
Actors, too, are going to get hit hard.
That's why I've been doing it for 35 years. When I
think of that industry, it's a
yakuza connection, and the
yakuza are in charge.  There was a time when I was there. It's
all like that. It doesn't come out on the surface,
but I
understand it. Somehow,
that connection led them to
go to each prefecture. It was a singer,
and even in Sengawa, back in the day, sumo was a
seed.  There is a sponsor called the town, and
behind the sponsor there are people like that.
Boxing has been practiced by the Sumiyoshi-kai for a long time.
[Applause] [
Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]  ]
I can do it I do
n't know I do
n't know how much is in it Please,
but I don't know how much is in it
[Applause]
[Music] Let's
move forward We'll
always be there Do
n't worry Vibrant la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la
[Applause]
[Music] La
La la la la la la la la la la
[Music]
This is my first time.
Well, there aren't many customers today, so it's
pretty lonely under the circumstances.
[Music] I
love boxing, but recently the
yakuza can't come to the boxing venue,
so it's been a long time since I came to box.
Everyone.
When Jim would do it, he would
bring swords and sell them all.
So, it's like the industry is thriving because of us. It's
like the
yakuza had the money.  The thing about being nice to everyone is
now all gone. It's
helpful. Everyone who goes out with you gets punished. You're in a
situation where you have to pay a fine. You gamble
every time,
every time. No, I
don't really do it today.
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
Gambling is no longer allowed under Japanese law.
In such cases,
baseball,
sumo, and
all sorts of written words like that
[Music]
Well, baseball is the base.  Ball was the most fun.
Ishii: I was
playing for 2.5 to 3 million yen.
6 games, that was
5 million yen. I
played every day.
[Music] It
's totally fine.
Nowadays, there are no customers like that anymore. There are
customers with money.  No, what's
happening right now is that Japan's economy is in decline.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause] Let's
talk.
[Music] No,
no, that's because you've been
excommunicated, so you do
n't need that. The
cursor won't appear.
Then, you see, you can
travel overseas.  I was also told that it would be a good idea to do something like that when I was exercising.I have to
go to work from now on.Okay,
when I get ready for that, please say hello again.Yes, I guess it's
because I can't eat the police and the motorway.
They came in because they admired it,
but now they
don't have that coolness, they
don't have that leadership ability, they feel like the
future is dark and it's
dangerous, and if they keep going like this,
will they become homeless?I'm a new group.
So
I started creating more and more jobs to support that kind of life.
Today, I decided to go to the shopping district where I created all the jobs and hold a festival
or other event.  The
Yakuza of today, the people who are called today's organized crime groups, are the ones who help the weak and are strong.The people who are called today's Yakuza are bullish and
bully the weak.It has
become reversed.That's why there is no path without
moral ethics.There
is no path of chivalry.  We've
become a repeat of violent groups,
so we have to create a new group that will serve the people
and the country.
That's my crime prevention association. It's
been 55 years since then, and it's now 8 years old.
But in terms of yakuza in life,
I think this is really the time for me, and
you all
know the glamorous and professional Ginza the most.It was
the most fun.
[Music]
[Applause] We live in a
bubble era.  I've
had a lot of experience, I've got what we would call 100 million yen now, I've got a million
dollars, and I'm a woman, and I'm sure she's a
good woman.It's
fun, it's fun, and I give
aid every day.
[Applause]
[Music] It was fun. I once
spent 56 million yen in a month.  I'm drinking
shochu right now. I
lower my eyes.
[Applause]
Things are
falling down.
That
good Ginza
doesn't exist anymore. Nobody has money. [
Music]
Once I've decided,
[Music] I don't know how to live my
life just because I feel like I have a cold.  It's completely
different. It's
easier to move around when you're a Yakuza, so you can confidently do
what the Yakuza have cultivated over the years. But if you
remove the sign that says you're a Yakuza to the police, you
can do it openly.
[Music]
[Applause]  ]
First of all, you were young,
right? Fast stories were popular at the time. They
brought in women to do
business, but
this is it.
So they put it on,
pitcher. They poured
dirt on top of the training toilet, washed their hands inside, and their
shoes fell off.  I said, ``No, bring it.'' It's
already fallen, so
he jumped into the store and asked Petey, ``I'm holding you up.'' You don't
remember, right? You
stabbed him in the heart, cut him in the
neck, and stuff like that.  I didn't do that,
but I don't
think it was just the way I handled things afterwards.
But what remains vividly in my mind is that it was my
fault for waiting for my brother. For example, Japanese people, for example, kill the other person.  You know,
when you're blinded to the extreme, you
fight against it like a cancer,
but the mafias in America and other foreign countries do it for money.I
think Japanese people
don't kill people for money.That's a
foreign country.  What's different from the Mafia is that
we have pride.
I once went to Suzaka prison in Nagano, where I was sentenced to 10 months in
prison, but I never
went to a place like this again because I thought I would never come back.
You guys can do anything different.
Mr. Nakao.  A
long time ago, I was involved with the Yamaguchi-gumi for 23 years.When you
go to prison, there are accidents, and
what you did can't be prosecuted criminally.Takeshi also
went to prison for 7 years.I
heard that he was a right-winger at Niigata Prison.
I didn't know much about it, but
everything
was taken away from me. I
'm a stupid man. He gave me
300,000 yen a month to take care of a woman's shop in Akasaka.
The man I toasted with was a man with a very bad drinking habit, and
you're a bastard.  When we got into a conversation, I
violently assaulted him on the spot and took his head off.
Katsura and Katsura
were shocked.
Later,
I told the Azabu police. However, in my case, I married my wife and my first woman.
Before that, I married my wife.  She was
arrested a week after the wedding, and
when she came out, she
was divorced and became a family. That's why she was so
cold. There was so much love. That's why
Makiko-san
had sex that day, and she thought about it like she was holding a doll.
Look, I
go to the Diet for my own pleasure, get involved in an incident, and have to
quit in my car.
Pleasure isn't the only thing in life, right?
[Music]
In a detention center. And
then my humanity will be over. Instead, in
a prison.  There's a rule, and
that's why it's
called naked dancing.
[Music]
Several people are watching through the bar, and they're
holding their mouths in their hands, and they're stepping over someone else, and then they're
straddling someone else, and then the next time.  Show me the lines on the soles of your feet.Then
turn around and show me your
asshole.Because I
showed you that, that's why we fight on the way there and back every day.The truth is that
America ignores humanity.  That's
not a foreign language.
[Applause]
[Music]
Temperature is a
sign here. I want to put up a sign, but the cops are making
too much
noise right now. No, I'll get arrested, so I'll put up a sign. I
think there are about two signs
here.  They have an office here, so I
think it's the mafia.
[Music] They
put up signs and say, this is a dangerous place. They're
doing it on purpose. If they're doing that openly, it's
bound to be easier to catch them. Isn't it a
funeral?  Because there
is a violent organization,
people who do things that cause a lot of trouble for cold people and do jobs that are not typical of Capricorns, I
think the police want to take action and destroy the very existence of this yakuza.  Well, there are things like
robbing a bank,
kidnapping someone, and
taking the ransom,
or, as we had a bit of trouble the other day,
taking a kidney instead of money.
Sho, you
start to feel like you can't
forgive them. You think they're trying to destroy you, but I
think that's having the opposite effect.
Well, I'm also a member of that program, but after
all, there's a boss and there are
rules, so he's the boss.  I've
never been told to do this or that bad thing, so I
think it's my fault when I was a kid in Katagiri.The
boss is my own parent, and what
those parents say.  I hear this from my own parents, so if
these bad guys still
come here and thugs come and enter this kind of world, gradually over the
years they will understand the rules and the
things that should not be done will be
done by ordinary bad guys or
fewer.  I think it's
not an organization that teaches bad things, so there
are city rules.If you say you opened a store now, you'll
have to talk to the person in charge.The
police will put uniforms on every child.
Even if you try to help others, your
reputation will be negatively affected.In that way, there will be
many people around you who will listen to you, and I
think you will receive many requests for advice.It's
not like I'm asking you to do that.  I do
n't think those people will come to
this
organization. It
would be bad if we only saw the bad things,
but I think it has good mana. It's
not like they're taking out their tattoos and washing them.
[Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] We
've known each other for five years. I worked with the chairman,
and Suzuki worked with the director. Well, we often came to the office, talked about
various things, and got along well. We
became good friends after a certain upbringing.  There was a
property there, and I tried to make money from it,
but it ended in failure, but
from that point on, the
two of us suddenly became friends.
[Music]
Well, there were a lot of experiments.
When I got into a bit of a quarrel with the organization, I tried to
capture eight of my opponents, and all sorts of other things happened.
Nakamura-san also got in trouble with me first,
but we're going to work together from now on. It
's difficult to make a living as a yakuza, but we're going to make
a living from now on.  We have to go
together because we both
have the know-how, so we have to
go out with someone who has a good heart.Humans.This is
going to get really big.The two of us
[music]
[applause]
Those who fight are called yakuza,
but now they can't
fight.If the
yakuza is strong, they're scared and won't do anything.If the
area is
weak, they'll feel like it, and they'll do whatever it takes to deter them, whether it's
drugs or drugs.
Power
comes from the yakuza.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] There
was a time when it was said that if there was cancer, a yakuza had to have a gun. People
often used their faces instead.  Nowadays, if you
commit a crime using a handgun, the
law against organized crime has been enacted, and the
weight of the crime is different.In the
past,
even if you hammered into an office, it took three or
four years.Nowadays, you can
break glass just by hammering in a gun.  It's been 9
years since I cracked it.
Young people today do
n't go there. It's become
very strict. In
the past,
there were 560 people walking around on patrol. Nowadays, it only takes 3
people to get arrested. Yes, you show your business card. In the
past, everyone who got caught was arrested by the police.  It was because of the yakuza that the safety of the area was
protected, but now
black people are doing whatever they want, drugs, women, etc.
About 10 years ago, an
organization of Chinese criminals was infiltrating Japan's downtown areas.  I've heard that there have
been many cases of murders of organized crime groups. All I can
say is that I've heard that there have been many cases of murders of organized crime groups. All I can say is that I've heard that there have been many cases where
Japanese organized crime groups have been killed by organized crime groups in China.  The
logic of organized crime groups is that they cannot do what they ask, and that they use their own strength to retaliate against what has been done to them, so I
think there were many cases where such things went unnoticed.This was 10 years ago,
20 years ago.  We don't currently have a situation where Chinese criminal organizations
went all over the country in Japan.The
future of organized crime will depend on what the social and economic conditions will be like in Japan in the future.  I
think the appearance changes depending on that.
Police crackdowns are necessary,
but if
Japan's organized crime groups were to be
truly destroyed by police crackdowns or other means,
then
Japanese organized crime groups would be there.  I
think foreign criminal organizations will enter the territory they had and start doing activities similar to Japanese gangsters.
[Music]
Bushido spirit is a samurai spirit.
Yakuza have a chivalrous split
spirit. This is useful.
Today's Yakuza.  This is because,
unlike in the past, if
education is weak and education is weak,
strong people will not
grow.This means that
people in their 60s are the most likely to kill people.  A
70-year-old goes on a murder spree.
This is something that today's young people are all too concerned about.
People who don't feel like they can kill someone unless they have the strength should
n't become a yakuza. They have to be able to
kill themselves if the situation calls for it.  The person who takes responsibility has to
do it.Yakuza
members are probably expensive,
so they have to pay 100,000 or 200,000 a month.They
can't pay it anymore,
so everything runs away.This is also a money collection system.This is the
system that collects money
now.  The Yakuza's servants are no longer able to function anymore, and the
bosses who cannot bring their own things are no longer able to bring them together.That's
why the pyramid of the organization is now
collapsing.Japanese
laws that do not recognize the Yakuza are becoming
more and more widespread.  If we keep cornering them, they will
become nothing. They will disappear from Japan. There will
be no more front-line yakuza, but the yakuza will always be
close. If it's a
right-wing group, it will
change its name to a religious group and
become a mafia. Even the police will
understand that.  But the
stupid police
don't pursue right-wingers. They do the same thing. They commit
criminal acts. I
think the mafia will become like the European mafia, the American mafia, the Chinese mafia, the Chinese mafia, and the Japanese mafia.
Yakuza.  I
would like to visit the grave from now on just to remove the name of the
person who made the first ball in the grave.On the anniversary of this person's death, I would
like to
visit it every month.Japanese culture  The
history of the yakuza is
important, and it is important to respect and worship God and Buddha.To put it simply, this is
connected to the religion that has been alive in Japan's history with the yakuza, and
I want to wipe out the yakuza.  I'm guessing that's
why they were created for that purpose, so the numbers
have decreased tremendously. For example,
yakuza ca
n't make deposits, ca
n't do bank transactions,
can't intervene in real estate transactions, etc. We
also have to counteract that, and if we do that, we'll be fine.
I
think we'll end up in a situation where they won't show us their work and won't cooperate with the police.The Japanese people will soon realize that if the police tighten their grip on us, it will
be easier for foreigners to attack us.This
man will
go to that office over there.  For
example, it's easy to catch people because you can easily see
them, and only you can know what plans they're neglecting when they
get together.That was when I started working as a criminal.I've been playing Go and scrapping it
every year.  The
most
memorable incident, and the most brutal one,
took place in 2003. There
was a town called Mimata in Maebashi, Gunma Prefecture,
and a
gangster was living a normal life at a snack bar in that town.  There was an incident in which they shot four people in the street
with a pistol,
and at that time, a gangster also
died after being hit by a pistol.
Originally, chivalry was about
defeating the strong and
helping the weak.  This
was also the main text of the ``Ninkyo'', but at that time, when
an incident occurred, as I said earlier, I was
responsible for the incident.  That's why I came forward, but that kind of strategy does
n't exist these days.Even if it's a
big
crime or a small crime, I don't get
jealous.Even if I know who did it, the gang or the
whole country
hides it or
runs away.  The
code pattern of the organization as a whole has also
changed tremendously compared to before.In
fact, since the Botai Law was
enacted, the number of
people who have come forward has actually changed.
Of course, the numbers that are working behind the scenes are different,
because the
numbers that appear on the surface are just
official numbers, but the numbers that are working behind the scenes range from
10,000 to 10,000.  I think it's a difference of 20,000.
Since the Anti-Bloody Act was enacted,
organizations have found it
extremely difficult to operate if they were given figures such as, for example, how many members a whole family has. However, the
number of people operating as an organization even though they are not registered is...
When my father was still alive, I often received letters
from my father.The police aren't very clear.Hey, there's an
earthquake.An
earthquake has occurred in Ibaraki Prefecture.Please prepare for strong shaking.It's here, it's here,
no, the earthquake is coming.  It's a strong tremor. Look,
no, you idiot. You're here. You're here. I'm with you,
dog. You've
made your decision.
[Music] I'm
in Miyagi Prefecture. I'm going to
visit an evacuation center and hand out beer to everyone.  The
last time I went to Ishinomaki, I went there as part of the Sumiyoshi-kai.At
that time, 10 days after the earthquake, there were 20 water cups and noodle
bicycles.The
locals had lost their cars, so I went to a
place far away in the city.  Everybody was happy that bicycles are the most useful way to go.It
has nothing to do with yakuza or citizens.Wow, that's
amazing.It's an
unimaginable world.There's
nothing, nothing
[Music]
Seeing the disaster area with my own eyes
Wow, I feel like something amazing has happened. It's
completely different. It's
amazing. Yes, I'm
home. I
can't cry anymore. I'm so empty.
[Music]
Look at this ship! Look at this ship! It's
full of cars.  Yes, that's
amazing. It's
scary. Nature is exactly the
same as Hiroshima and Nagasaki. It
hasn't changed at all after the atomic bomb was dropped.
Even the yakuza's enemies have been scary.
But this natural environment,
like tsunamis and
earthquakes.  This is something I never
thought about, so I
went to hell.I went to school.The point is,
until yesterday, everyone was
living their school life here.Then, even though the
cityscape came, I took refuge on the roof of that school.  I've
heard that everyone was saved. It makes me
sad to think that everyone has gone back to the world of zero and nothing. My
whole family is against it, and I'm from Kumamoto, and
Kasagi is the one who uses drugs in the countryside.  My
parents often told me that I shouldn't just become a yakuza.Family
is the most important thing.  I
think this is what a family is: an organization that starts something, and receives money, even if
it's not a salary.It's not that, but it's an individual who writes everything.Then,
if there was no mutual help, now just
one person gets better.  If one of us gets better, there will be
people who will hold us back. They'll
report it to the police.
This is
n't a family.
Well, I have three girls, so why are they
avoiding me? I
asked them what they were doing.  Well, when you get bullied at school,
what kind of bullying do you get? I've seen
quite a few
people with yakuza tattoos come here, so I'm sure it has nothing to do with young people being
bullied for being members of the yakuza. Well,
then.  When I went to school and asked to call my wife and parents,
I said, ``
But I don't have a wife at that time, so please don't do
that.'' When everyone became colder,
I felt sorry for them.If I
really killed everyone, then
that's why I decided to
divorce.  I took it
because I thought I'd be happier if I wasn't with her, so I
've been in touch with her on the phone from time to time, but we have
n't seen each other much.Since the recent earthquake, it's been about 6 years since I last
called her, and we talked about this.  If we're going to
get married, then why don't we get married? I
look at my dad,
happy and drinking. After all,
family
is a good thing.
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
He's my grandson and his name is Chikara.  He's
8 years old or
8 years old. He's my second most powerful brother. He
's only 3 years old. My
grandpa is a yakuza. I
want to see him.
What do my grandpa's friends think? I
think he's cool.
This is a very difficult and important thing because we are a family.In
order to protect this, we must
live strong and have the
spirit to sacrifice when it is necessary to sacrifice.Hello
How You
[Music]
Real Family  And also,
this is a family meeting, and there are things that are
extremely important that need to be thought of more than family members.For some
reason, they are not
connected in any way, but
just by drinking one cup, it will go
down.That's why I
wrote it down and put it there.  It's not hard, but when it comes to metal
[music], there are certain
things that can't be avoided, like when you don't have to
apologize to someone for heating, or when you have to do something you don't want to do because of a traffic accident, etc.  That's why we have to
go to prison, which is called prison time. It's a
very painful thing, and I
don't want my son or grandson to have to go through that kind of thing.
[Music] So,
how many classes did the teacher have?
[Music]
Gumi I've
been cracking down on organized crime for 37 years, and
even though I've been cracking down on organized crime for 37 years, there
are some people who don't understand anything at all, even if I do my best to investigate them.That's because human sensors are different.
Well, when the
investigation is over, the
court has decided on the punishment, you
go to prison, and
when you come out of prison, it
would be fine if I was the only one complaining at my age, but the
attack on my family, including myself, is that.  It's
true that there have already been two incidents.It
's scary, but it's
scary, but I was
approaching it with the mindset that I was doing it for work.The person whose
family was destroyed because of his drug use, and
his life.  The idea was to help
the children who were entering elementary school at that time to participate in the
project on behalf of the residents who were sentenced to prison, and I have
even attended the sports day.My
family is still involved.  That's
why I took care of him
several times in place of his father while the rest of his family went to
prison.He has
57 children, and
although he is 70 years old, he can wait for a child to be born at any time.  Whether a
son
becomes a yakuza or a gangster, his
parents have nothing to do with his son's life.If he makes a
mistake, he will fix it himself.If he gets in
trouble, he will fight the other person himself.If he
kills the other person, he will go to
prison.Presentation
Depending on the situation, you may be killed or killed.
That's okay. That's why
my only son died two weeks ago and three weeks ago this month. There
are still two people who have died in other countries in the past. In
that sense.  My own son
dies. I have no choice but to choose this path. It's my
son's problem.
Parents raise their children when they are children. The rest is up to their sons. Their
daughters' lives are their own, and they
raise them on their own. It's a
mistake.  It can't be
helped that they're going to be crushed. They're going to get killed by mistake.
Ah, Koriyama. There was a
fight a long time ago.
I caught them, so 8 of them came by car. You'd
think it was strange since about 8 of them came all the way to Fukushima, all with tattoos on their faces.  That's
stupid when you're in a fight.From the
promoters of things like boxing, from the
entertainment world, everything is almighty.So
then you can get water for 25 yen.500ml is enough for the
disaster area and they say they don't have enough, so
water.Hmmm.  So this time, I was going to clap for 1 night and 2 days,
but they decided that I should just stay for
1 night.I
already knew that I couldn't send e-mails, but they said I was
n't allowed to drink at the evacuation center.
I understand, but
since it's times like this, I'd like to have some beer, so I brought it with me. You can
drink beer inside, but there were some people who were drinking it,
but we don't do that
because we drink with men.  I didn't say that,
thank you very much.It
was the 9th year since I had worked so hard to build it.Even though I had
lived like this, I
looked at the corners of my eyes when I received things like that, and I
was filled with tears.
When I went to the evacuation center, I heard from the woman that a
cobra had come in the dark,
but I
have a feeling that she must have been really scared,
so I couldn't do anything about it.The
important thing is
Everyone looked at me as if my skin was
telling me something, and
I also
talked to someone who was about 69 years old, but
when I thought about things like, ``Maybe this person is going to die,'' I
didn't have the words to say.  I felt
sad,
but everyone
looked at me with happy faces, as if they wanted to drink it.The
image of everyone happily taking it with me is
etched in my mind.I
just drank it.Thank you very much.
It's been a
long time since I've had a drink, so I
decided to do it until it rose to the sky, rather than the flowers I was decorating.On the other hand, I also
climbed up to a high ground, but there was a cenotaph-like monument a little
higher up.Well, it
had been destroyed,
but
there I was.  I think all the people who had homes
came out and
saw an indescribable scene. They couldn't even talk to us.
[Music] The
sea in Shibaura was a
man's
life.
[Music]
Why did things suddenly
become so harsh?
Against the yakuza.  I do
n't understand this. There are so many
scammers these days, trying to
deceive the elderly. It seems like there are always a lot of scams and
acts of violence. There are too
many bad things. There are too many
things I regret. I
don't understand. Because of my
personality, I
cause a lot of trouble to people.  I
wish I hadn't done this, I wish I hadn't bullied myself so much.The
reason is that I
drink and eat too much.I've been repeating this over and over again, only drinking alcohol, eating food, and not sleeping.After
all, my body is
screaming.  I'm a
diabetic and I'm selling something called insulin
right now.I'm about to get a job, but I can't decide on anything.Everyone in the
Yakuza is suffering from
depression.I was like that too.If you have
no dreams and no hope, things
will get worse and worse.  I
don't really know what the law is about, but I can't afford to rent a house on my own, and I have to
move out of the place I live in. They do
n't even give me my health insurance card.
This is a situation.  They're
animals that aren't considered human beings.
Sakura is already done with it. It's like that again
this time. You
regret quitting the Yakuza.
But you can't say that. From now on,
I've decided to do my best.  In terms of work, the
more yakuza there are, the better.
Nowadays, there
are fewer yakuza than in the past, which means
fewer customers. Yakuza
can't make a living with good bosses like that.
There are a lot of bosses who have quit.
[Music] The
second person, the third person, I'm the 8th person, and
now I'm the 9th person.
When it comes to creating laws to crack down on yakuza,
politicians are the easiest to create.  Well, let's
wait for the yakuza,'' someone says.When
politicians
create laws that are convenient for the government, they first target the yakuza to
create a ball.If that's the case, then there
is absolutely zero opposition to that.
If the bill passes, it will apply to yakuza as well because it is a
law, so it
can be applied to other things.  It
really should
n't be that way. All people living in Japan have to be equal. I guess it's the
constitution. The
best thing to say is that yakuza can't go to golf courses, and
now you can't
sell your car to yakuza either. You'll get sick sooner or later.  There's also a
possibility that the doctor will say no because you're a yakuza.In that case,
wouldn't a yakuza be unable to treat a disease?Isn't this treating you as a human being?Isn't
this a violation of the constitution?The same
goes for animal societies, too.
Whenever someone disappears,
it always comes in. There was one here. If you
hit it with a bang, it will drop, and after a while
another one will come in. Whether
it's a Japanese mafia or a foreign one, it does
n't matter.  Three things are good money.As long as you make
mistakes with people, no matter what you do, they will never
go away.I
feel lonely, but in the end,
I think the yakuza are a necessary evil.In the end, the
current
security situation in Japan is  For example, the Chinese mafia
and other
delinquents
roam the streets at night, and the number of
stupid crimes is increasing.
The area was properly
managed, and that's what the police were really
tightening down on, and
while the number of yakuza is decreasing, the number of different types of crimes is
increasing, so in my personal opinion, I
think it's a sad thing.  It's natural to
crack down on yakuza who are doing bad things, and I
want them to be cracked down on more and more.However, some of them
cooperated with the so-called security of the town, but gradually they became more
violent, and I
want them to become anti-violent.  Well, I think there are
some people who are going in a bad direction because of things like that,
but I think it's a matter of cracking down on people who are saying that. It's a
normal thing to say, but it's just a human being. It's too
much.  That's something that's been amazing lately. I wonder if it's
okay to go this far.
For example, if you were an ordinary person, you would never get caught urinating while standing. It's gotten to the
point where you're already being prosecuted for something like that.
So this is a little scary. In short, it's a bit scary.  When
state power reaches that level, there
is a tendency for them to become fascists, which is scary.In
my long
experience in cracking down on organized crime groups, I
have come across the idea of ​​a "cup-of-the-pants" system.
Even organized crime groups inherit that Japanese culture.  The
reality is that they take action, and
I have high praise for them for
that.It
is one of the actions that these people who respect others must take.
It's not a organized crime group, after all,
people come in from other countries.The people who come in have the quickest job, which is to
buy and sell drugs.It's okay to say that foreign people
cause incidents in Japan.  I do
n't know about it, but it's a rule for Japanese organized
crime groups to protect their own islands,
so I guess it's
important to protect them at times.
Of course, there are special worlds that the police society can't touch.  It is in this kind of world that
Japan's organized crime groups are
exposed,
foreigners coming in from other countries, and
foreigners coming in from other countries
not committing criminal acts in Japan, and the
Japanese people looking
at existing organized crime groups with a different
perspective.  I think it's because it's different. When I
became the protector of Ginza, I
thought I'd start over from scratch. Well, I
tried my best, but
with everyone's betrayal, I kept getting into trouble.
Well, that's the saddest thing.  I
feel
lonely and
don't know what to do.Well, I didn't
pay the rent, so I had to
move out.Well, I was
asked to pay 2.5 million yen in rent.  I
joined because I was told that I could use this place,
so I thought I'd join if I had a good job.Since
1937, I
said it was a drug, so I
don't know anything about the enemy's work, so I don't know
where they've gone yet.  I haven't decided what I'm going to do.
All I know is that I have to get out of here. I'll stay
here after dark. I
won't give up. I'll still do my best from scratch.